[Music]
fire base makes Google OAuth extremely
easy and web apps but if we're building
a native mobile app with ionic there are
some additional considerations we need
to think about for iOS and Android when
logging in we can't just use a regular
browser popup window or URL redirect
like we would in a web app instead we
use a Cordova plug-in to access features
that are only available on the native
mobile device in this video I'm going to
show you how to implement Google OAuth
from scratch in a way that works for iOS
and Android
as well as progressive web apps if
you're new here make sure to subscribe
and you can follow along with the source
code at angular firebase com I am
starting out from a brand new ionic app
and setting a custom ID that we can use
to register our app with iOS and Android
on the firebase console your ID should
follow a format of com dot brand name
dot project name just to give you a
heads up this episode's going to have a
lot of long commands like this but you
can copy and paste all of them from the
main write up the next thing we'll do is
install firebase and angular fire 2 into
our project and lastly we'll need a
component in ionic for our Google login
feature if we jump into our app at this
point we should be able to go into the
config.xml file and you should see your
project ID that you set from the command
line as the widget ID but if starting
from an existing app go ahead and update
the default ID to whatever your project
ID happens to be now we can set up our
mobile apps in firebase so you'll go
ahead and add an app to your project and
we'll start with the iOS configuration
all you have to do is enter your project
ID and then go through the steps you
don't need to do anything else other
than register your app with this ID that
takes care of iOS for Android we have an
additional step for local development
we'll start by entering the same project
ID like we just did but we also need the
debug signing certificate to enable
Google+ from our local development
environment you can obtain the
certificate from the command-line and
you'll need one for every machine that
you use in the development of this app
you can copy and paste this command from
the main article and then you'll type in
the password of Android that should
generate the certificate which you can
then copy and paste and add it to your
project in fire
then you can click through the remaining
steps but you don't need to do anything
else other than register the app now we
just have one more thing to do and
that's install the ionic native Google+
plug-in and the corresponding Cordova
plug-in and it's important if you are
targeting iOS that you set this reversed
client ID variable you can find the
value by going back in the firebase
console under your iOS app then you'll
find it in the Google service plist file
now we're ready to start writing some
code first I'm going to import
angularfire and Google+ and you'll want
to add your own firebase config here
then we're importing angularfire in the
import section and Google+ down here in
that providers section in my up I have a
dedicated login page but you could
easily drop in the component we're going
to build into any other page so in this
case I'm setting my root page as the
login page then I'm declaring the Google
login component in the page HTML now we
can jump into that component and build
our cross-platform login feature we're
going to bring in angularfire auth as
well as the Google+ service and platform
from ionic platform will allow us to
determine if we're on a native app or a
web app then our component is going to
have a single property which is the user
observable that we get from angular fire
- and we'll go ahead and inject all of
our dependencies in the constructor then
we can define our user in the
constructor by calling the angular fire
off state the first method I want to
define is Google login which gets
triggered when the user clicks on the
actual login button what we want to do
here is first check for the platform if
the platform is Cordova then we know
that we're on a native mobile device so
we'll run our native Google login method
otherwise we can just run our code for a
regular web application login our login
methods are based on promises so I'm
going to define an async method called
native Google login and I'm also going
to wrap it in a try-catch block so we
can catch any errors if they occur
during the login process on a mobile
device we'll first need to get the ID
token from the Google+ plug-in to do
that we call a weight Google+ login and
then we have a couple of configuration
options that we need to pass to
the important one is this web client ID
because this allows us to take the token
from the login and then use it with
angularfire too you can find your web
client ID by going into the Google cloud
platform console go to api's and
services and then go to your credentials
tab you'll need to use the web client ID
that I have checked here then you can
simply paste it in or set it up as an
environment variable when that resolves
it's going to give us the Google+ user
but we want to use it with angularfire
too so in order to do that we call
angularfire off
sign in with credential then we'll
reference the Google auth provider from
the firebase SDK and pass in the ID
token that we just got from the Google+
user because our users an observable
it's going to omit the user data once
this operation is complete and lastly we
can catch and console.log errors if we
also want to deploy as a progressive web
app we're going to need a regular web
login we can use the same async method
pattern wrap it in a try-catch block but
this time it's even easier we just
referenced the Google auth provider and
then call sign in with pop up the last
thing we need to do here is give the
user a way to sign out first we'll call
the angular fire off sign out method and
then if the platform is cordova or a
native mobile app we can also call the
google+ logout method from here I'm
going to switch over to the HTML and the
first thing I'll do is unwrap the user
observable using the async pipe this
weird-lookin syntax is either going to
give me a user object or an empty object
set to a template variable named user we
know that the user is logged in if that
object has a user ID so we'll set up an
ionic button and if the user is not
logged in we'll give them the option to
trigger the Google login method
otherwise if we do have a user we're
going to show that user ID and give them
the option to logout from here you can
go ahead and run the app in an emulator
in this example I'm running an Android
studio on the pixel too and you can see
we get this native login flow as opposed
to a web browser papa
we can also test it out in Xcode with
the iPhone 8 and we should get a similar
process there as well and if you want to
see an example on the actual App Store
check out the what's up app that was
built by an angular fire base Pro member
using ionic and similar technologies
mess around with it and give the Creator
some feedback on our slack team the
invite link is in the video description
if you found this video helpful please
like and subscribe and if you're serious
about building ionic apps consider
upgrading to a pro membership you'll get
twice as much content every week and
exclusive resources designed to help you
build and ship your app faster thanks
for watching and I'll see you soon
[Music]